sie wollen endlich Freiheit ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben sie wollen ihr
Land zurück
Tod dem Diktator haben wir haut endlich
ab so schalte es seit Tagen überall in
Iran
die Wut der Demonstranten ist zu groß
wie nie weg mit diesem Regime so ihre
Forderung und ganz vorne mit dabei
tausende mutige Iranerinnen
wir Treffen sanars in Istanbul die in
diesen Tagen kaum noch Schlaf findet in
ständiger Sorge um Familie und Freunde
in Teheran sie ist eine von 180.000
iranischen Bürgern die inzwischen in der
Türkei leben aus Furcht vor Rache Akten
der iranischen Behörden möchte sie nicht
erkannt werden
sie haben das Internet und alle
Messenger gesperrt ich habe keinen
Kontakt mehr zu meiner Familie
ich fühle mich hilflos junge Menschen
die für ihre Grundrechte und ihre Träume
auf die Straße gehen werden gerade in
ihrer eingesperrt und getötet und ich
kann nichts tun
es sind diese Bilder die sie um den
Schlaf bringen brutale Polizeigewalt
gegen Frauen die aufbegehren
mit mehr als 60 Toten bislang seit zwei
Wochen demonstrieren sie in vielen
Städten Irans fordern das Regime heraus
mit bonnertov Cocktails und Steinen
gegen den Unterdrückungsapparat Filmen
dürfen wir die Proteste nicht
iranischen Behörden drohen unverhohlen
jedem der über die Proteste berichtet
mit Gefängnis es soll nichts nach
draußen an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen
mehr als 1000 Menschen wurden schon
verhaftet darunter viele Journalistinnen
und Journalisten und das Internet ist
gesperrt sowohl WhatsApp als auch
Twitter Facebook Skype alles geblockt
trotzdem gelangen immer wieder Videos
ins Netz
diese Iranerinnen und Iraner sind fertig
mit der Islamischen Republik sie wollen
Grundrechte Jobs ein Leben in Würde Weg
aus der Steinzeit wo bärtige Männer ein
Volk willkürlich knechten
kennt dieses Gefühl sie arbeitete in
Teheran für ein großes Staatsunternehmen
zum Alltag gehörten Willkür Korruption
sexuelle Übergriffe als Frau sagt sie
erstickte ich letztes Jahr packte sie
die Koffer es geht um viel mehr als nur
um das Kopftuch und willkürliche
Verhaftungen sagt sie
diese sogenannte Sittenpolizei behandelt
Frauen wie Verbrecherinnen du weißt
nicht wohin sie dich bringen sie nehmen
dir dein Handy weg du darfst deine
Familie nicht kontaktieren der Druck ist
unbeschreiblich wenn Frauen sexuell
misshandelt oder vergewaltigt werden
haben sie praktisch keine rechtliche
Möglichkeit dagegen vorzugehen
das Regime versucht derweil mit
Propaganda Bildern den volkszaun zu
überspielen Präsident reisi ermahnt zu
Beginn des neuen Schuljahres züchtig
verhüllte Schülerinnen unbedingt an den
Prinzipien der Islamischen Republik
festhalten kein Zufall sagte ehemalige
Parlamentsabgeordnete saderie das
Kopftuch sei praktisch die DNA dieses
Regimes
es ist das Symbol der Islamischen
Republik schlechthin das sehen auch
regierungsanhänger so deshalb wird der
Kopftuch zwar nie aufgehoben werden
allenfalls die Methoden zur Durchsetzung
des Zwangs geändert
die bedrängten Machthaber organisierten
Gegendemonstrationen wie hier in Teheran
mit tausenden Angestellten aus dem
Staatsapparat und den religiösen
Stiftungen wer seinen Job behalten will
der folgt der behördenanordnung und
schwenkt hier Fähnchen für den obersten
Führer harmony
ich glaube die Regierung sollte noch
viel energischer gegen diese
Aufständischen Vorgehen sonst wird der
Schaden für uns alle nur noch größer
vordergründig geht es um Kopftuch und
Islam tatsächlich aber um Geld macht um
den Erhalt des korrupten Apparats die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung lebt inzwischen
an oder unterhalb der Armutsgrenze die
aussichtsloser die Lage desto schärfer
die Reaktion der Macht haben jemand der
sich im Innersten Zirkel der Macht
auskennt ist der Theologe Mohammed
abtahi vor 20 Jahren war er
Stellvertreter der Staatspräsidenten
catami er forderte eine Öffnung der
Systems die Konservativen ultras-stecken
in dafür ins Gefängnis eine Basis für
Reformen sei mit dieser Führung
praktisch nicht mehr vorhanden sagte
tief im Inneren völlig korrupt und da
viele an dieser Korruption teilhaben und
davon profitieren ist der Kampf um
Reformen aussichtslos das Regime ist im
Selbsterhalt erstarrt
auch deshalb wird trotz der großen
Gefahr der Ruf der Demonstranten nach
einem Regimewechsel immer lauter das
musste auch Revolutionsführer cheminey
beim Blick auf sein instagram-konto
erfahren unter dem Hashtag masamini eine
Flut wütende Einträge Schluss mit der
Islamischen Republik ist noch der
vornehmste für senars in Istanbul sind
die Proteste ein Zeichen der Hoffnung
auch wenn sie zugleich um das Schicksal
ihrer Freunde zu Hause bangt
das Regime hat durchaus sozialen
Rückhalt und es hat bewaffnete Scherben
Tee werden nicht kampflos die
Futtertröge räumen
ich weiß nicht wie das ausgehen wird
aber ich hoffe für meine Landsleute dass
sie diesen Kampf gewinnen
iranspolizei könnte ich doch heute einen
noch härteres Vorgehen gegen die wir es
heißt konterrevolutionärer an und
Präsident reistin nannte die
Demonstranten feindliche Verschwörung
das Regime so scheint es Krebs sich
weiter ein die Wut der vielen
unzufriedenen wird sowohl kaum
besänftigt werden
[Musik]